- Welcome back y'all.
We are here with Joel McHale
and Danielle Pinnock in the house.
(audience cheers)
I first met our next
guest a couple years ago
when he joined my team on The Voice
and my sister first fell
in love with his voice
and she was like, "I love
this guy on your team."
He's an awesome musical talent
as you heard at the
beginning of this show.
But he's an equally awesome human
which is what I love most
about people on my team.
He has a new single
called "Close to Love."
Let's welcome Corey Ward, everybody.
(audience applauds and cheers)
So, lemme introduce you.
This is Danielle, this is Joel.
- Hello. Hello. What's up?
- And we've had a bit of
wine, Corey, so there you go.
- [Corey] Yeah, I'm jealous.
- I'm trying to keep
it together. (giggles)
(Danielle laughs)
I'm warm all over. Okay.
I met you in Season 20-
- Yes, ma'am.
- of The Voice.
But you had auditioned
the previous season as well, right?
- [Corey] I did.
I, I never planned to do a show like this
and I never cared for,
but my family's watched
the show for years-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- and they begged me to do it.
And I was like, "No, I
don't care to do it."
- I'm glad they pushed you.
- [Corey] Yeah, I know.
But I was like, I, I
don't care to do that.
But they're like, "Listen, do it."
And I knew when my Mom
ended up getting diagnosed with cancer,
and I was like, "You know what?
If I'm ever gonna do something
like this, it's now."
Because I wanted something my
family could just celebrate
instead of hang out in that-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- just sad, darkness kind of thing.
But I was like, here we go.
And then I didn't get chairs on 19,
but came back for Season 20,
and I knew that I wasn't done.
My Mom ended up having a
small seizure during 19
and my family couldn't be there.
So I was like, all right,
that's why I didn't get chairs.
And I came back and I
was like, you know what?
Now my family's with me now I got it.
And you know, I was excited,
and so glad that you turned for me.
- You know what it is, (audience applauds)
timing though.
Like it's,
even in all of our careers,
there's timing when things happen
and your whole spirit isn't into it,
emotionally you're somewhere else.
Like, that happens to all of us.
I'm so glad you picked me.
How, how do you, how do you think you'd do
as a contestant on one of those shows?
I wanna know your style.
- I would, I would get the show canceled.
(laughter)
Are you kidding me?
- Honest to God,
I think you being on Blake's team
would be the best television ever.
It would be the best television.
- I'd probably sing, "Let's
get Drunk and Screw," but
(laughter)
- Which is why you
probably would pick Blake.
It's like coming home.
So tell us about your new
single, "Close to Love."
- Yeah. "Close to Love."
Um, when I write, I really
want it to be relatable.
Again, just connect.
And what it's about is basically
getting in a relationship
that feels like love
and being scared to leave
it because you're like,
"What if I never get this close again?"
- Ooh. Ooh.
- [Corey] Because so many people get stuck
and feel like they gotta stay in something
because they're afraid of like,
what if this is the best I can get?
- [Kelly] It's a comfort zone.
- Yeah, it's a comfort thing.
And I just wanted to break that and,
and relate people with that.
Like, I think we've all
been there at some point.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And it also kind of, it's
almost like "Already gone,"
which I've sung on the show.
- God. You sang it better.
It's literally the only
time I've been like,
"They just sang it better than I did.
That's cool. Fine."
(audience laughs)
- That made my life.
- I'm not, and by the
way, I wasn't kidding.
So it was-
- [Corey] It means a lot.
so moving, coming from a,
the texture of your voice
and you could feel that
you meant the lyrics, but.
It's almost like the
opposite of "Already Gone."
- [Corey] Yeah, exactly.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's the the the push
and pull of each other.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I love that
and I connect with you a lot musically
and, and that's why I
was so blessed to be here
and very grateful for you.
- Oh my gosh
I can't wait to have you
back singing more music.
- Hey, I'd love to come back
and sing one of my singings.
- I love it.
- Yes, let's do it.
- [Kelly] It's so, it's so good.
I love your voice so much.
- [Corey] Thank you.
You like, make my heart
smile. It's so good.
- It really means,
words will never be able to
tell you how grateful I am.
- Well, I love having you on a team.
It's always awesome.
Like I get, people don't get it.
Like, a lot of us coaches,
John and I talk about this a lot too.
You get re-inspired in
like a different way
working with-
- [Corey] Yeah.
- these artists because
it's like, well it's true.
Like because people,
I think sometimes we can get jaded.
When you're in any industry
for a certain amount of time,
you, you start thinking
you've heard everything.
And then you like, you're sitting there
and you just hear something so magical
that like hits you.
And that's beautiful.
That's a gift.
- Yeah. Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Anyway. I love you.
You know this. I'm gonna keep gushing.
Um, thank you so much, Corey.
- Thank you so much.
- I can't wait to see you
come back sing some more.